[Music]
hey what's up welcome to D LM model
lifestyle I am Daniel and in this video
we're gonna talk about ten things that
men like about women
[Music]
number one is a cheerful attitude there
is just something about a woman with a
cheerful attitude that makes men really
like them especially if you're a little
bit playful and you make some jokes and
you just make a guy happy just life is
just so much better with a cheerful
woman number two is how a woman look and
dress the way a woman looks and dresses
herself it really tells a guy a lot
about her and what she thinks about
herself so you don't have to go
overboard ooh
especially warning to those girls who
don't leave anything to the imagination
please cover up a little bit because
most guys will not respect you as much
and I will think you're cheap I'm sorry
I'm just I'm just being very honest
because I know what guys say if they're
alone in the room alright number three
is a confident woman
guys like a confident woman there's just
something about a woman that walks and
talks and just carries herself with a
lot of confidence not arrogance but
confidence number four is kindness every
guy out there loves a woman that is very
kind because he knows that she's very
empathetic and that she'll be there for
him
when the time comes that he really needs
her number five is being family
orientated it just shows that you're not
just selfish but you care about the
family and also most men they want to
get married one day right they want to
have kids so seeing you being family
orientated they can get a picture of how
you would be when they're married
number six is when a woman is ambitious
guys love it when a woman is a go-getter
when she's ambitious since he's working
towards a goal and she's just born every
guy loves that number seven is loving
and affectionate
I have never met a guy that does not
like it never never
number eight is being able to compromise
woof it's so hard to deal with a woman
that cannot compromise it's impossible
you don't have to say yes to everything
but the willingness to be able to
compromise means a lot to a guy
number nine is when a woman asks for
help yeah it sounds silly but most guys
out there want to feel that they are
valuable to you that they can help you
of something even if you can't open a
jar just ask the guy to open the jar and
you'll see him be like all confident and
say yes give it here
number ten is being accomplished and
fulfilled a woman should have her own
interest her own hobbies and feel great
on her own as well as in a couple and
just a bonus tip if you like games
that's it boom that that's it forget
about all the other tips if you like
games boom
play a game with a guy here and there
even if you don't like it just show him
you know you want to try and do
something with him you're gonna see how
much he's gonna appreciate it
alright those are my 10 tips if you have
another tip put it in the comments below
so we can check it out and if you did
not subscribed yet please do
thanks guys Cheers oh my goodness so
many noises here
let's try again being accomplished and
freakin throw
hey bro I'm chasing birds numbered bird
my goodness I'm gonna be here the whole
day yeah Shh but confidence seriously
there's just something about a woman
that has new month right okay let's try
again
[Music]
[Music]